Joe is Frank Gore a hall-of-famer you
know it's interesting that discussion
you're having right now is sort of the
discussion that seems to come up almost
EPS here with the Hall of Fame and in
Cleveland the discussion was around the
Clay Matthews senior died a bright you
know 200 plus NFL games but never had
that high star of you know five-six Pro
Bowls all pros in a row and so you look
at from the voters standpoint how much
are they weighing longevity into their
decision on are you all of famer are you
not and it seems from recent history
that NFL Hall of Fame voters are more
interested in guys whose star has
reached that apex versus a guy that had
a super long career as a really good
player thank you for bringing that home
and not giving a full answer but I'll
say this
Clay Matthews is 58th on the all-time
sack list with 83 and a half sacks he's
tied with Laroy Glover and Leonard
Marshall right in front of former
Redskins great and the other and Charles
man opposite Dexter Manley
I love Clay Matthews he did play a long
time I think he should get serious
consideration but Frank Gore's fourth on
the all-time rushing list I'm sorry I'm
getting why am i yelling so to me he's a
Hall of Famer anyway Joe how are you
thanks for being here thanks for taking
the time I know you're moving a lot this
week okay well let's let's talk about
the Odell thing if we could because you
know I'm a fan and part of me is afraid
to be excited because as Browns fans as
you well know you've had reason to be
excited in the past and then bad things
happen Joe tell me that I'm nuts
well you're not nuts it's like you know
Christmas morning and you're looking at
your presence and you got that big box
that's wrapped under the tree it looks
exactly like what you'd ask for but you
don't want to get too excited until you
actually unwrap it and are able to lay
your eyes on that present that you hope
it is and that's the same thing that
right now with what has happened with
the Browns in the offseason an obj in
specific we know what we think he is but
until he's in that room until he's in
that Stadium with Baker Mayfield and
he's able to make those plays and we're
able to see all this talent on that
roster play good football together I
think brown fans as a whole will
probably have managed expectations going
into the season and that's actually not
a bad thing I think it's important for
all the great moves that they've done
this offseason to still understand that
there's a lot of work to do before you
just show up on Sundays and start
winning football games and I think that
would be really good thing for that
football team could still have that chip
on its shoulder even with the infusion
of talent that they've had the thought
that said I'm excited but I am still
reminded of the fact it listen I know
and I've had people text me and say will
you just sit back and enjoy it and I
said yes I am enjoying it I am excited
it is March but Joe as you know 371 days
ago we were talking about this team
being Owen 16 and what are they gonna do
the Jarvis Landry trade hadn't been made
no one could figure out why I mean I'd
say no one but there were still people
confused as to why Hugh is back and his
Dorsey gonna make a splash and to go
from that to this it almost seems like
too much too soon
yet you look at them on paper John you
good dams are good well it certainly is
very exciting if you're a Browns fan but
you did mention that Cleveland fans
Browns fans as a specific we've we've
been burned in the past specifically
coming off of my rookie season we were
10 and 6 we thought we'd found the
franchise quarterback of the next decade
with Derrick Anderson and then we had
some injuries early on in the season and
then 2008 just didn't turn out the way
we had all hoped and the coach gets
fired and then we kind of went down the
rabbit hole of firing coaches and GM's
and didn't find our way out of it until
John Dorsey comes to the rescue so I
think it's natural you know as a Browns
fans we've been burned before and it'll
be more fun and more enjoyable I think
if we let ourselves be surprised by the
success you
you talk about this a lot with Andrew
Hawkins on your tomahawk podcast for
those who don't listen to it download it
you should listen to it you guys have
taken a couple of weeks off but I know
you're back now tell me why you know
tell me why Baker Mayfield has the
demeanor and and not only that the
football ability certainly but the
demeanor to handle the the I don't call
it a powder keg but all these
personalities now being thrust into this
locker room
yeah there's two reasons the first
reason is he is of the same generation
of all as all of these other stars and
we actually just recorded a new tomahawk
today and we talked a lot about this he
has an ability to relate to all those
stars in that locker room that a guy
like an Eli Manning or some of these
older quarterbacks that are stars in
their own team in their own market don't
have that ability to relate and I think
the breakdown for me as always did you
grow up in middle school in high school
with social media because I feel like
that is a big generational divide and
for a guy like Odell for a guy like
Jarvis for a guy like Baker they're able
to speak the same language they listen
to the same music they like to hang out
together so there's an ability to
understand you'll each other off the
field and I think that strengthens a
bond that they'll be able to use in the
locker room when things get tough
because no matter how successful you are
as a team you're gonna have some hard
times and there's going to be some hard
conversations and there's going to be
some heated battles in that locker room
especially when you have all these
players that want the football but being
of the same generation I think is a huge
benefit for Baker but the other thing
with Baker is his leadership skills we
saw already in his rookie season
Stephen natural born leader we sought it
up at Oklahoma and so for him I don't
think that's going to be an issue at all
because people are drawn dat his
personality they're drawn to his
personality and I know you can attest to
this when you talk to him for five
minutes you step back and you go alright
I get it now like I I see what other
people see and he has a
rare ability as well that people want to
now come play there with him which this
team has not had absolutely right when
you have that young quarterback that
star like a Baker Mayfield all of a
sudden now he's recruiting other stars
to come to your team that's that's what
added benefit more over and above what
you get from just his performance on
Sundays on the field talking to Joe
Thomas here the future hall-of-famer the
former Browns left tackle now a
colleague of ours at NFL Network we were
joking a couple of days ago about
putting weight back on for those who
don't know how much weight have you lost
Joe I'm down about 50 pounds from my
last season in the NFL but if you add up
when I was really chubby in 2012 I'm
probably 75 pounds and we were joking
about you coming back to play and you
said obviously that the current salary
structure for left hackle is not enough
for you to put the weight back on in all
seriousness has any one so it's been
what like a year in a month year in two
months whatever since you retired did
anyone call you with a serious offer
last year no and I think potentially if
you talk to my agent Peter Shaffer he
may have said somebody may have reached
out to him but I think he knows just as
well as ideas he's seen those MRIs of my
knee and my hip my back and he knows
that there's it's not even worth picking
up the phone and asking me because he
knows what the answer is if I was able
to still play with his body I would have
done it last year there was no reason
for me to retire I love the game
obviously the paychecks are unbelievable
and I love the locker room everything
about it I loved it was just your body
when it's ready to give up there's not
much talking back that you can do and so
really it's almost made it easy it's not
like one of these things where now that
the cream is really good I'm having
second thoughts because it was strictly
a health decision and I know I just
can't do it anymore
was there I'd ask but you brought it up
was there a sense of feeling left out
when they did win last year
no not really I don't but I would have
because I I could kind of see they're
not happening with the moves that Sachi
made when we were there and then the
moves that John Dorsey has been able to
make and you see this talent being
acquired and then all of a sudden you
fix the quarterback positions like yeah
you know it's going to happen now and I
kind of thought there would be maybe
some jealousy in me or some of that
wishing that ah man I wish I could still
be out there but I have not experienced
yet I think part of it is as a player
forever you're always training yourself
to just control what you can control and
don't live in the what-if world and I
think that's kind of cleared over and
I'm totally accepting of my position
right now where I am in the fact that
the Browns are gonna be really good and
I'm not on the team anymore but I'm just
happy to be a fan like you right now to
be able to enjoy it and I'm just gonna
live in the moment well you're also
doing really well on television as well
and you don't need me to tell you that I
don't know though what the Giants well
thank you sir I mean and I mean it I
don't know what the Giants are doing
however I understand if you go the guy's
a headache we don't want him here
anymore it's not worth that headache but
then Joe when you see them get rid of
Landon Collins who's a 25 year old when
you see them spend money on a veteran
receiver like Golden Tate who I like a
lot but it I don't know what their plan
is can you figure out the Giants plan
I'm scratching my head just as much as
you are when when they traded Odell I
was fully expecting them to sort of be
on the same plan that the Browns were
about three years ago where they're in
this deep rebuild multi-year rebuild and
to three years they're going to be
saving salary cap space and trading back
into the draft to collect more picks for
future years but then last year they
drafted a running back number one
overall and running backs don't have a
long shelf life so you don't want to be
burning up hours and miles on your
all-pro running back in years you don't
think you're going to win
they've got a 38 year old quarterback
and now they're signing Golden Tate so
it really doesn't make sense the moves
they're making are not giving us a clear
idea of the direction of that franchise
because some of the moves they're making
you're thinking okay they're making this
for the future because they know they're
not going to be very good for a couple
years but then all of a sudden they try
to make a splash and try to cover up the
hole by signing a Golden Tate it'll be
interesting to watch them because we
can't really figure out where that
franchise is headed last question for
you and once again we appreciate your
time we're gonna ask you the poll
question that Brockman put together
today Brockman you want to want to get
out the poll question at ASCO we opened
with the Francoeur question that your
purse is wrong about and now we're gonna
ask you this go ahead who finishes with
the most wins this coming year Joe it's
the teams that made the kind of a
splashy astray ders Jets Jaguars we
added the Steelers because of what they
lost well that's an easy question we've
been talking Browns all week in the
great moves that they've made so I think
out of that group but that's an easy
answer that the Browns are gonna be
finishing with the most wins of that
career and that that's that said without
bias right without any bias of course
never doubt you Joe Thomas who has truly
done a great job all week at NFL Network
as he did on Thursdays and whenever else
he was on last season Joe I know they're
pulling you 50 ways this week here and
asking you to do this show in that show
so I appreciate hopping on the phone
here for 10-12 minutes this morning you
probably have better things to do like
work out and lose more weight so thank
you sir you got it Joe Thomas everybody
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience